slicers anonymous a very funny short
comedy film starring kevin nealon
actor comedian saturday night live
former cast member
and he joins us on the program kevin
nealon how are you today
can you hear me yeah can you hear me
wait nope that's now we can't hear you
nope
no
no no you you were okay but now you're
not
is this the first time you've ever done
this no i play mommy all the time
i put him back in the case and they went
on now
now we're in business yeah we're in
business now it's not a good business
but we're in business no no we're good
we're good how would you describe your
uh golf game
uh almost non-existent
because uh well because
a i'm not that good
b i haven't played in about a year i
might have played once or twice
i just had my shoulder replaced um a
month ago
but so i am preparing to get back out
there and then my game will be good
but is it similar like have you done
pro-ams
have you played in this oh yeah okay
i've played tons of pro-ams more nervous
playing in a pro-am
or doing stand-up
oh definitely a pro-am but i'll tell you
a pro-am
ties or is is second
as far as nerves as throwing in the
first pitch at a baseball game
professional baseball game what game oh
my gosh
i had to throw the first pitch in for
the cubs versus the white sox at wrigley
field
and i hadn't thrown a hard ball in
forever
so i get i get to uh by the way i love
all the trophies you've won
on your desk thank you i get i get to uh
i get to chicago i'm doing a gig there
and i gotta throw the ball in the next
day so i figure i'll get up early and
i'll go to a park
near the hotel and find some kids
playing baseball and i'll ask if i can
throw the ball around a little bit kind
of warm up
so i get there and all i can find is a
little rainy there's a dad playing with
a six-year-old
and i don't even think it's a hard ball
and i said i couldn't find anybody else
i said would you mind if i
i could play catch with your dad for you
guys a little bit because i'm throwing
the first ball in at the game today
and i think the father thought this poor
guy
never had the father-son experience and
he wants to have it
[Laughter]
so the kid sat on the sideline i threw
the ball to the father a few times
and then i felt bad for the kid so i
said okay i think i got it and i go to
the game and i'm so
nervous i i really i haven't been this
nervous since the first time i did the
tonight show with johnny carson
and my legs are weak my knees and they
give me the jersey i still have the cubs
jersey in my
in my closet and um there's actually
pictures uh
on on i don't think maybe i could even
find one here
but um so i throw the ball in
and it's a high fast ball and i was so
glad i didn't ground it
because if you throw from the mound
that's what people if you throw in front
of the mound that's that's the the route
to take
when you get on the mound you inevitably
either throw it really high or you throw
it into the dirt
yeah but you gotta throw it from the
mountain you can't get in front of the
mound
that's like a for an old president to do
you know but
you were never that nervous on saturday
night live
no because i will tell you dan i the
year before i came on the show was
almost
canceled because the ratings were so bad
and it was so panned by the press
i thought nobody's watching the show you
know nobody's going to get
uh you know i mean how much worse can we
do
not that they were a bad cast the year
before so just the synergy wasn't there
with the writing
so um and also i've done comedy clubs
where there's been that many people it's
a small studio there's not that many
people in there
and and i'm pretending the cameras have
no film in them
and my first sketch is mr subliminal
which is kind of a
you know it's a double conversation
going on at once so it's a little
complicated
and five seconds before i go on lorne
michaels the producer
puts his hand on my shoulder and he says
are you sure this is what you want
but how did you come up with mr
subliminal mr subliminal
was a um it evolved
from a guy i met a character actor ed
peck
back in the 80s the early 80s late 70s
he used to do
shows like um happy days and laverne and
shirley he always played the cop
in a deep voice you know like lower brow
voice and
and he took a liking to me and we went
to cantor's this delicatessen in
hollywood uh after he would always come
out and hang out the
improv where i used to pretty much live
and uh he would uh
he said i'm gonna do this thing to the
waitress uh i want you to pay attention
and so he would uh order from the
waitress he'd go uh
i think uh i think i'm gonna have a uh a
cheeseburger [ __ ] and why don't you
also give me uh
you know and he put in these these vocal
words profanity
you know so just under his breath
yeah yeah so he says you should do that
in your act you should try that so i
started trying it in my act
and then when i get to so now i got with
al franken and al franken
uh said we should do this like as a
subliminal advertising guy trying to get
his way for things you know
and i knew about subliminal advertising
because i went i have a bs in marketing
so i studied advertising
so that's kind of how that came about
when do you know that you got something
on saturday night live when a sketch is
working yeah
um well it's funny you never really know
because it's always you know when you
come out of the gate it's a little bit
foreign to the audience they're trying
to figure out what you're doing like
when dana carvey and i came up with
hanzo franz
uh the people enjoyed it the first time
but they weren't really sure what we're
doing they're taking it all in
and thinking okay these guys are
austrian bodybuilders they don't lift
weights
they just make fun of people and then it
resonates with them i think
after that and then we didn't do it for
i don't know a couple of shows and then
i thought dana why don't we bring back
hans and franz
and uh he goes yeah let's do that so we
wrote another one
and as as soon as we appeared on stage
the audience went crazy so
we knew during that that period of time
in between the two sketches it had
resonated with people and they were
thinking about so they were happy they
liked these characters when we came back
they embraced us and they they loved it
based off schwarzenegger
yeah yeah yeah just a couple of guys you
know they think
they're hot stuff you know and
everything's about them and you know
everyone else is a loser
does that sound familiar did he respond
oh yeah yeah it's funny you know at
first you think oh man these people are
gonna get mad at us for making fun of
them
and it's it's really quite the contrary
people like i remember dana would do
casey kasem you know and casey would
send him
cases full of uh cds
because he loved it you know it only
brought attention to these people and
arnold loved it you know he took those
characters and he ran with him because
we were
we said you know what distant cousins of
honors
he's our cousin no he's he is the
perfect embodiment of papa tude
and so when he ran for governor he was
using all of our like catchphrases like
you know don't be the girly man you know
don't be a loser
you know you got to vote for me i'm the
perfect embodiment of governance
he's uh kevin neal and actor writer
comedian former saturday live cast
member and uh working with callaway the
new
newest bertha b-21 we just watched uh
the uh the video there um you your
catchphrase is
your slice is not your swing
your slice is not your swing yeah
explain well a lot of people have a
slice you know most most people that
golf are not good
i remember uh golfing once at um at um
um i'm going blank on the name of it you
know up by
um the att
pebble beach pebble beach pebble beach
yeah and um i said to my caddy i said
you get a lot mostly good golfers on
this course he goes no
no they're mostly bad all bad just
tourists they want to golf on the course
so um you know most people are not good
golfers and they have some kind of
something going on their swing like a
slice
or something you know and uh so this uh
callaway approach this philosophy is
it's it's not it's not your what's it's
not your slice it's your swing
your slice is not your swing your slice
is not just yeah you're slicing
this way are you sure that you're
why do i know more about it than you do
and you're in the commercial
i couldn't remember the name of pebble
beach how am i supposed to remember the
name of the catchphrase
it's uh so is the guitar just a prop
because you used to be in bands didn't
you
were you in garage i was in garage bands
and i i love playing the instruments
what's your go-to song on guitar
uh the one i'm learning right now in
fact last night and this morning because
during covet i'm you know i'm i'm
learning a lot i'm learning how to paint
i'm learning songs that i never finished
there was a song i heard somebody play
on instagram that i remember that song
that's a cool song
and it's uh by crowded house don't dream
it's over
i sing it all the time do you really yes
around the studio i sing it we brought
it up yesterday on the show
can you grab your guitar you play let's
go
i'm not a good singer but i'll play it
all right you sing it you sing it
this can't be pretty
i don't know the words
[Music]
don't dream it's over
hey now
[Music]
you know what to dan i never like knew
lyrics i don't think i know the lyrics
any one song except for maybe happy
birthday
best musical act you saw on saturday
night live
that's a really tough one because we had
so many
so many of these like uh you know dyna
these
these dinosaurs that i grew up listening
to like keith richards mick jagger
paul simon james taylor eric clapton uh
uh uh you know um did you get to hang
with him
yeah yeah they would actually sometimes
they would play afterwards when the show
was over they do a little concert they
play like
three or four more songs like paul
mccartney and paul simon and
um and i was always a big fan of james
taylor so when he came on i kind of
befriended him
and uh he said you know i you know i
always say this but you know
maybe we should go out and get dinner
sometime you know and get together
and i'm thinking oh my god james taylor
sweet baby james asking me out on a date
did you ever go out i did i went to his
house in new york i went up the elevator
i was shaking like a leaf i was like uh
going on a date
and he opens the door and he's got his
jacket on he's ready to go he's ready
for me
and we go to this cuban restaurant on
broadway it was great we hung out and
then
went back dropped him off on the whole
way back and thinking do i hug him
do i kiss um you know i don't know what
to do uh
you can uh check out uh kevin he is uh
pairing up with callaway the newest
bertha the b-21
and uh your slice is not your swing also
kevin's youtube show
hiking with kevin and uh it's always
great to talk to you kevin we hope
you're doing well
you too dp thank you man good talking to
you
kevin nealon callaway golf youtube
channel
slicers anonymous there